Oh
the Peter G Peterson annual fiscal
summit today included interviews with
key members of Congress and the Obama
administration this discussion of the US
debt and tax rates is a little less than
two hours
good good morning happy Washington
weather day nothing like it
we got a powerhouse hour that we're
gonna do we are gonna solve the budget
crisis right now there's going to be a
deal they all won't if they're not gonna
appear together yet but by the end you
watch will have senator patty Murray
Congressman Paul Ryan
they'll be back there in a room they'll
solve this deal and maybe they'll
announce it in about 62 minutes but
before then we are gonna talk to some of
the key players in the administration in
Congress and see where we're at because
I'm sure a lot of you are like me and
you're probably wondering when it's the
budget talks gonna begin
maybe they began on a golf course
yesterday who knows with the president
and and and some senators so without
further ado the the lead person for the
Democrats in the US Senate chairman of
the Budget Committee senator patty
Murray from Washington State
morning when you said Washington whether
you were talking about my Washington
state whether we have your weather here
it's raining and what is it right now
it's you know 80 in Seattle so something
happened that we have sort of messed up
the Washington's there somebody needs to
realize which Washington's supposed to
get rain
alright simple question to begin this
with where are we in this in the Senate
in the in the Senate excuse me in the
budget negotiating process well as you
know I became chair of the Senate
Democrats in January this year and the
of the budget committee and began to put
together a budget which is now passed
out of the Senate the house has passed
their budget and in a regular order
world which they have been calling for
for a long time we would appoint
conferees in the Senate the house with
appoint conferees and we would begin to
sit down in an open transparent way and
work towards a compromise but
unfortunately at this point the
Republicans are objecting to us going to
conference so I find myself in a very
difficult position unable to negotiate a
deal if you started no formal
conversations you begun with Paul Ryan
who is your counterpart on the house
side have you had informal conversations
yeah Paul has asked that he and I meet
together and discuss some of the issues
out there but you know we've been
through this world before where if
you're in a closed room and there's two
of you you're not going to get to a deal
this evolved involves all of Congress
that involves all the country and the
country really needs to see what the
alternatives are you know when the
reason that a budget is important is it
really outlines our path forward in the
country it defines where we're going to
be and who we are what our investments
are how we're going to manage our debt
and deficit it defines not just today
but tomorrow we can't do that with two
people in the room we need to have
people from both sides coming together
to compromise that's what legislation is
all about all right even folks in this
room might be a little bit confused by
all the various budgets that are out so
you guys have a budget House Republicans
have a budget and the president has a
budget what's the common ground between
all three right now you probably study
all of these budget
as well as anybody what's the common
ground where we could begin the
negotiating process well that's that's a
really good question and I think that
obviously the house budget in the Senate
budget and the President's budget which
is similar to ours are fairly far apart
I think the common thread is that we all
recognize that the debt and deficit is
impacting our country's ability to
really make sure that our economy is on
track that we have you know we know
where we're gonna go that businesses
have certainty and that we need to find
a path forward I think the important
part that we are looking for is a
balance in solving this issue in making
sure that everybody in America
participates in helping to solve this
problem that's why the word balance is
so important to us that there are both
spending reductions and revenue which
every bipartisan committee has supported
to move forward with why doesn't your
budget balance well in fact our budget
losses towards balance and if you go
back and look at simpson-bowles and all
of the diminutive Rivlin every
bipartisan recommendation that has been
put on the table
doesn't put out an artificial date to a
zero balance and the reason is is
because our economy is extremely fragile
today if we were to just immediately put
an arbitrary date and cut
you know trillions from our budget we
would really impact a lot we're actually
starting to see a small part of that
with the bad policy of sequestration
that has been imposed upon us because we
don't have a budget yet and we're gonna
see more of that effect as it moves
forward it's extremely important that we
get our economy strong again that we
provide security to people that we get
back on track as a country and manage
our finances in alarm you said that the
President's budget in your budget are
pretty similar but there's one glaring
difference and that is this issue of
entitlements change the the so-called
chained CPI which would change the way
cost-of-living is done you know some
Republicans criticizing it as a tax
increase because it would change tax
brackets but it would hit Social
Security benefits this is not very
popular among members of your party it
said for
no it's not popular and I think that it
does have a huge impact on seniors in
their Social Security when everyone
agrees it's not Social Security that
caused the deficit the president has
said his budget is not a perfect
solution but he put that out there as a
way to say my door is open to finding
some compromise here and I think what he
is waiting for what I'm waiting for I
think what Democrats in general are
waiting for is for the Republicans to
walk through that door and say you've
compromised a bit we're willing to
compromise on the revenue side so do you
think that the Republicans aren't
interested entitlement reform arnux are
they really interested in it because
they don't have a plan out or do you
well you think that it's the only thing
to judge them on right now is the Ryan
budget which is we all know that arises
Medicare which is that's you know just
not going to happen I think that in this
country and this time in the history of
Medicare and the where our country is we
know that Medicare is extremely
important to provide stability security
and medical care for the seniors today
and in the long run the question is how
do we do Medicare policy for the long
run to make sure that it is solvent in
the future which we have as a party said
we know we need to do we're willing to
put some what some what's an idea that's
on that isn't in this budget isn't in
the President's budget but they should
be well actually I would disagree with
you in our Senate past budget we put in
an additional two hundred and seventy
five billion dollars in reduction in
Medicare over the next 10 years and that
is a significant give we recognize on
our committee that we have a number of
people senator Warner senator wire you
get this money by the way this is coming
out of of reimbursements to doctors is
this out of hospitals or is this from a
budget merely says the numbers and and
in directs the Finance Committee to it
but I can tell you having chaired the
super committee numerous conversations
that we went through line by line to say
what are the changes that can be made
that don't impact beneficiaries but
make the problem that solve the problem
in the long run President Clinton was
here earlier this morning talking about
some of the ways that we need to look at
health care in the future not just for
our Medicare population but for our
entire country it's consuming our
country at this time in terms of
expenses we as Democrats are willing to
look at those long-term proposals and to
make adjustments in our programs and to
determine how we can do that but again
we can't solve this problem just on the
backs of Medicare and senior citizens
and hardworking families everybody has
to participate in this debt and deficit
problem that we have
that's why revenue is so important is is
there anything that's a non-starter when
it comes to entitlements is it raising
the age on Medicare is the voucher for
Medicare proposal which simply shifts
the costs and creates a system that is
not sustainable in the future so you
know we're not going to undo Medicare
with changes but we certainly can look
at ways to reduce the cost silver and
anything that's a non sorry could you
could you grudgingly accept what the
president did on chained CPI on Social
Security if it's part of a larger deal
well I think again I don't think that's
a good solution I actually think most
people don't think it's a good solution
within this but it is it's a starting
point he put out there that's a
discussion on what we politically people
in it out there you guys on it is that
well I it's actually a Republican
proposal to start with but you know
they're saying they don't support it
because it raises revenue so maybe it is
a non-starter because everybody agrees
they're not going to go there but I
think there are a lot of other things
that we can look at in terms of getting
our debt and to a manageable place in
this country and again this is really
important look by not having a budget
deal today
I mean it's Washington DC speak but by
not having a budget today what it means
to businesses and families is that they
are having to live with very bad budget
decisions sequestration is a very bad
policy we are beginning to see the
of that and it's going to roll out more
in the coming months and in the
following years if we don't replace
sequestration with a budget proposal
that defines where we're going to make
our cuts and where we're going to make
our investments and where the revenue is
going to come from
when does this is it gonna take a crisis
again is the debt ceiling coming up
actually something that everybody in
this process needs in a weird way
because it sort of forces action it
seems like the only time that any deal
has happened is when there has been the
proverbial gun to the head of Washington
well if there's nothing else I say today
that's important let me say this our
country is tired of Congress managing by
crisis it has brought us to the point
where we are at today with bad policies
bad implementation sequestration being
the most visible right now and I believe
that we have a job as Congress and I
think we should get to work putting
together a budget that's why going to
conference is so important to me and to
my caucus and to many republicans that i
talked to as well because managing by
crisis puts our country in a very bad
place when our economy is fragile
compromise is not a bad word it is part
of what we have to do in this country I
come from a big family we have seven
kids growing up I mean you don't get
what you want for dinner every night
but you realize that sometimes you know
you have to make changes so what have
you been at this is you've actually been
arguably you were in oh you've already
been in a conference committee on this
super committee sure you brought it up
there were key Republican I mean this
was six and six I'm not mistaken three
from sort of every caucus six Democrats
you were the chair there what went wrong
if you guys couldn't solve it then when
the sequestration gun was to your head
how house conference gonna go any
difference between you and Paul Ryan
well I think
several things first of all what we ran
into having worked many many hours to
try and come up with an agreement was a
line in the sand from the Republicans
that no revenue would be included and we
just could not solve this entire problem
on the backs of a working class public
who was struggling so much from the
economic disaster that occurred that
wouldn't be fair it wouldn't be balanced
it wouldn't be what the public was
asking for what changes today well we
had an election where the public said
yes we want a balanced approach we want
both spending reductions and we want
revenue and Republicans would say you
got revenue that's 6-under billion
dollars in revenue and I will remind
everybody two things every bipartisan
group that put together a proposal
recommended much higher revenue than
just the 600 billion we are asking for
those kinds of balanced proposals moving
forward and secondly what we are talking
about today in our Senate budget is
closing some tax loopholes that even
Republicans Speaker Boehner and Paul
Ryan have said wasteful spending we'd
spend so much time in Congress going
after cuts to discretionary spending and
calling them earmarks we have the same
kind of earmarks and tax expenditures
that need to be looked at and and are
they good for our economy are they
benefiting just one class of people are
they working for all of us and that's
the discussion that Speaker Boehner has
agreed we need to do but they will not
include it in you brought up their
proposal you just brought up tax reform
so it segues to our Facebook question
which is from Lisa Burke from Seattle I
believe we need a combination of revenue
and spending cuts to address our debt is
tax reform the solution to getting
revenues without setting off a firestorm
about new taxes so it sounds like what
she's saying is can there be a static or
lowering of rates that raises the
revenue you're looking for can
everything be accomplished that way oh
and what she is also putting forward is
the premise that we need both that spin
cuts and revenue and the question is
fair and legitimate and in fact in the
supercommittee and in our Senate budget
we have looked at tax reform as a way of
bringing revenue to help solve the
deficit problem the difference right now
is that the proposal that the
Republicans are looking at does tax
reform only to cut the rates for the
wealthiest Americans to give them a tax
break we are talking about tax reform
closing loopholes looking at tax
expenditures to help balance our budget
which benefits the entire country and
sets us on a better path you know you
keep talking about widening it you know
there's been some is there enough
individuals paying taxes into the
government you know you hear this
argument sometimes in the Republican
side that everybody needs to pay more of
their fair share on this front so the
idea of the different crazy do you think
a tax reform deal that that sort of has
people people in lower income
contributing some tax dollar is
something that gets through I think what
the Republicans are proposing is
lowering the rates on wealthy Americans
the rate but what that does if they're
saying it's revenue neutral is actually
raises the taxes of everyone else I mean
right now being able to write off your
first mortgage is credibly important to
a lot of middle-class families taking
that away is a huge impact so the tax
when they want to lower when they want
to lower the rates revenue-neutral
somebody is raising that right the
reason taxes on side and have you
identified where that tax hike is coming
from well they haven't identified it
they've just thrown out a target number
and if anybody credible has looked at it
it's very clear that in order to raise
that kind of revenue that they would
need to be revenue neutral from lowering
the tax rate is going to require a lot
of middle-class families to lose a lot
of what they use this deduction you were
just at a dinner with the president last
week I want to say hosted although 20
women senators there's 16 Democrats for
what Republicans in their nature the
conversation how much of it was focused
on the budget issue and did you walk out
of there any more or
les convinced that a deal was going to
happen this year well I was very
impressed with the conversation that we
had the 20 women who had dinner when you
guys get together monthly this is
something the women of the Senate have
been getting together this way ever
since
Barbara Mikulski started this long 20
years ago and it was a very good
conversation a lot of it was about the
budget and what was impressed me the
most is Republicans and Democrats alike
in that room and we run the range
liberal to very conservative were very
serious about the budget issue and in
those in that room to almost to a person
I think said I'm willing to take a tough
vote if everyone does that gives me hope
so I think we put the 20 women into a
room we could probably come out with a
deal I've heard this a number of times I
don't disagree on that last question and
it's sort of a silly out question but if
there is no deal this year is it fair to
say there's not a deal until after the
next presidential election well look
here's what how did i ad answer that the
American public all of us are tired of
management by crisis it is hurting our
businesses it's hurting our families and
when I took on the supercommittee the
one thing I said was I want to find a
solution to the deficit problem but I
also want to show the American public
that a democracy can work if we are
forced to another budget crisis
manufactured way of getting to a budget
deal that's going to reinforce the
American public our country can't work
so I say let's not get there we need to
start working now in conference
committee in trance full transparency
the president is reaching out to a
number of Republicans he is looking for
people who are willing to work with us
I'm hearing from Senate Republicans that
they are tired of management by crisis
let's show the country we can work my
door is open I'm ready to compromise
I know Democrats are and we are ready to
work with our I'm tempted to just so
value belief Paul Ryan is next and
waiting in backroom I intended to leave
the seat we should let you guys
negotiate it out in public
but I will say the double zeros are on
the clock senator patty Murray hey thank
you for coming and thank you so I
believe it is Paul Ryan that's next time
my apologies if I've got our order wrong
there he is he's right there come on
let's see the big let's see the embrace
come out here in public negotiations
could begin in the green room coming up
is the Senators counterpart in the House
House Budget Committee Chairman Paul
Ryan from Wisconsin hrs okay so what we
learned from good morning we start a
little process we get a little policy
and we'll end with a little process and
we'll start with process then policy the
next process you know this is washing
sounds exciting yeah different you lucky
when does this when do the talks start
Democrats have said senator Murray said
they're waiting for you for you guys to
sent the negotiating table she said
right you want to meet with her 1i1
but the regular order Harry Reid last
night tried to get it started the Senate
Republicans blocked them on that when
does this one of the o'clock start so we
do want to go to commerce but we want to
go to conference when we have a good
chance of actually getting something
done the reason we think it's not that I
want to get a deal I want to get an
agreement we don't go to commerce just
for the sake of going into conference we
want to go to conference when we think
we can get an agreement the problem we
experience and this is more of a house
thing than a Senate thing is if we go to
conference and have a months-long
stalemate in conference what ends up
happening is people dig in their
positions and it makes it that much
harder to get an agreement at the end of
the day that's your lesson from the
supercommittee it is my lesson from the
supercommittee so know that our
motivation is to actually get to an
agreement and the decisions we're making
right now are to make it to maximize the
the likelihood of getting an agreement
at the end of the day does that mean you
passed that you believe you guys pass to
political of a budget and they passed it
a little over budget do I want my budget
to become the law yeah if mitt and I
went one we were planning on you know
putting it together but I get that in
divided government you
get everything you want and so we
understand that let me give an example
the president should get credit for
putting chain CPI out there wasn't in
our budget wasn't in Patty's budget he
put it out there let's assume for the
sake of argument that that might be part
of a final deal if we go to conference
early I can guarantee you'll see votes
on the House floor prior to going to
conference where virtually nobody votes
for it and it makes it that much harder
for it to be part of a final dry I mean
why would John Boehner Eric Cantor cut
McCarthy allow that to happen they
wouldn't the Democrats can get control
of the floor when you have a conference
after 20 days that hasn't come during
the green seasoning demo we would
surrender of the majority and so we
think that we want to go to conference
when we have a chance of getting a deal
and that means if you have a months-long
stalemate where the two political
parties are just fighting each other
then you make it that much harder to get
in agreement
I'm not saying John Boehner and Eric
Cantor would let a vote like that happen
they would lose control to weather that
kind of a vote would happen or not and
that's why we want to make sure when we
go to conference we're we're gonna get
something done and this is where we have
such huge worlds apart patty was pretty
clear about that yeah
our budget balances takes ten years to
balance and so I would argue from a
Keynesian standpoint we're not hurting
growth by balancing in ten years the
problem is the Senate budget and the
President's budget never balances ever
so we have a disagreement on whether we
should even balance the budget that's
number one number two both the Senate
budget the president's budget have large
tax increases stacked on top of the 1.6
trillion dollars of tax increases that
have already occurred in law starting 5
months ago where do you get 1.6 train
but Obamacare tax increases in the
fiscal cliff tax increase I think that
the the the health care tax increases
are a little bit in dispute on some of
those numbers whether they'll go a CVO
so surly and put fair enough so you're
saying no more tight this is you can
start negotiations that have that but
they want to say we agree to raise taxes
and then we'll later maybe talk about
some entitlement spending or some
spending cuts which we right now won't
agree to any in principle that is hardly
a smart way president initiating
president did but not people were
dealing with in Congress so I'm not
trying to get you know ask Waller here
but the point is spending is the problem
for the last 60 years we've taken about
20 cents of GDP to spend for the federal
government by the time my three kids are
my agent will be taking 40 cents out of
the economy to spend for this federal
government at that time that is the
problem you need to reform entitlements
you need to get spending under control
and then when we see the other budgets
offered which is let's take the
president's budget for example take the
smoke-and-mirrors away it's about a 1.1
trillion dollar tax increase with nearly
a 1 trillion dollar spending increase
both the Senate the President's budget
have net spending increases they don't
even propose to have net spending
decreases so that is that is a very
different world from the one which we're
operating off of and they were very far
apart so what we're trying to do is have
conversations where we can find common
ground I think you asked patty where
does this exist there's really one thing
that I've seen in these budgets of the
three budgets of the three but one piece
of string you think yeah means-testing
is the one stream of commonality I don't
know if not all but it's but on the
president's budget he does means-testing
for Medicare we propose means-testing
for Medicare that's about all you see
with respect to common ground the point
is there are spending cuts which are
very few are out washed or out bid by
the massive spending increases and so we
want to say let's agree that we're gonna
get spending under control let's agree
on some entitlement reforms that they
may not affect current beneficiaries
we've never proposed that but let's
prospectively so we get this debt under
control and we can't even get an
agreement in principle to begin talking
about that right now
what do you what do you say to hurry so
we there's whether there have been
various studies on on how to deal with
this the fiscal issue and all of them
proposed higher tax increases than what
the president ended up what you guys
ended up grudgingly coming to an
agreement to a trillion that people have
thrown other numbers there's 800 they
did clearly Speaker Boehner was willing
to go at least another 200 billion where
the president's number was maybe it's
another 400 billion maybe it's another
600 billion but it didn't seem even in
Washington numbers didn't seem like
we're far far
all right yet to two points I would
guess I'd say what they're saying is
raise more taxes to spend for more
spending we don't like that construction
the second thing is we want growth the
one thing that seems to be missing in
this conversation all too often is what
are we doing a girl the economy what are
we doing to get people back to work what
are we doing to have faster economic
growth we have more revenues which is
one of the best things we can do to get
this deficit under control especially in
the short run and this is where we think
tax reform is extremely important and
when you're talking about tax reform
something we're going to be moving
through the Ways and Means Committee and
something we're very serious about
something we would like to see in a
final agreement you think that has to be
part of the so-called grand bargain
whatever it is I wouldn't I don't think
we're gonna have a grand bargain a grand
bargain implies you're gonna fix the
problem but when you have the majority
party in Washington unwilling to embrace
the kinds of reforms that make Medicare
solvent or make Social Security solvent
which are the big drivers Medicare's the
biggest driver of our debt in the future
I don't think I don't see a grand
bargain happening so the question is can
we make divided government work and can
we get a down payment on the problem can
we buy the country time in fiscal space
that's what we're shooting for something
that's realistic we don't want to over
promise and under deliver because I
don't see up a grand bargain happening
she said voucherize Medicare that's not
what our proposal does but it's what you
know it's what pollsters say to say it
is we think premium supports a smart way
to go it's how the it's how the drug
plan works today it's what the federal
employees have we think that's a smarter
way to save Medicare in perpetuity
there's no way they'll agree to it I
would imagine and so that means
comprehensive anti-tumor reform which
takes that on front of milk liability
off the books
gets this debt under control and
perpetuity those kinds of ideas I think
are not do regret that basically you
whether you believed you were doing it
at the time or not that you've
essentially contributed to the
demagoguing on Medicare when you guys
ran against saying the president was
trying to cut seven hundred billion
dollars out of Medicare you know that
hole do you regret that conversation
because then it it hurts your
credibility as you're trying to have a
Medicare reform conversation look we
never thought you should take money from
Medicare to spend on our new entitlement
that's what we've been criticizing if
you look at Mike
Russians of this issue I never thought
it was a good idea savings I never
thought about it I did because what goes
to Medicare if you're gonna take money
from Medicare it should go to Medicare
solvency
you can't take 716 billion dollars from
Medicare spend on creating Obamacare and
count it in two places
you can't count it for Medicare and then
count it on Obama but you can make the
argument that if you reform the health
care system is going to help reform
Medicare down that's not the argument
that's being made the argument that
they're advancing is this money helps
drive down the deficit and make Obama
care cost lists and it extends the
Medicare solvency the Medicare actuary
the CBO both told us you can't spend the
same dollar twice so the fiscal charade
the double counting that's what we have
a real problem with if you're gonna save
money in Medicare keep it with Medicare
to extend Medicare solvency so you don't
regret the language that was used
because you you you you said both parts
of the sentence here usually no the
campaign simply a lot of times shortcut
it and simply said and there's the
president trying to slap let me speak to
that issue and frankly I've watched both
parties do this right demagogue Medicare
to their own both parties both parties
96 and Clint's you guys in 2010 and time
not going to dispute that the point I
would say also is look at our budget we
think that there are problems with the
Medicare provider community we think
that these provider cuts are gonna lead
to Medicare beneficiaries losing access
to coverage so we put a provision in our
budget saying we need to redress this we
need to look at where in the Medicare
beneficiary network are we gonna have
inadequate coverage and let's go back
and look at that so through the point
that the dependi was making earlier with
where she has 275 billion I think she
said in Medicare as the target number
didn't say what it was out of providers
is what they're saying that's on top of
the 7 to 16 which we still think is
going to basically it effectively shut
down the Medicare provider network we
see that as a monopoly money we see this
idea that we're just going to keep Trice
controlling Medicare providers to get
all this savings as sort of a repeat of
1997 a bipartisan agreement Newt
Gingrich and Bill Clinton came together
mm-hmm
they put price controls and Medicare and
what we learned quickly after that was
Medicare providers just stop taking
Medicare patients so we did two
subsequent agreements to give that money
back to the provider network and the
savings
did not materialize as they first
envisioned we don't want to repeat that
mistake the lesson we learned through
the head doc fix by the way the
documents are as part of their we call
the sniff cliffs for nursing homes and
other things the point I'm making is
taking this entitlement not reforming it
and then just putting price controls on
providers does not work and so we don't
see that as real budget reform we see
that as sort of a phony exercise where
we know as soon as provider stopped
dropping coverage we'll will put the
money back so that they don't drop the
coverage and so we don't see this real
lasting bankable reform the point I'm
trying to get it is we want entitlement
reforms that we know will stick that we
know will work that we know will help
reduce the unfunded liability we have in
these programs that will help get the
debt under control and back to my
earlier point we need economic growth
and this is why we're very serious about
tax reform think the sequester is
hurting the economy
I don't think taking 2% off the top in a
in a you know 1415 trillion dollar
economy is going to be a big drag on
growth I think in some sectors like
defense they're clearly dislocations
that are occurring this is why I passed
two pieces of legislation one in July
one in December to have smarter spending
cuts in other areas of government to
make government more efficient to
replace the sequester you can remember
the house twice passed legislation
saying the sequester is not smart it's
bad policy we didn't insist upon it in
the first place and here are better
spending cuts to replace the sequester
we stand by those cuts we think those
were smarter cuts the problem is the
Senate never followed suit the president
said just give me a tax increase instead
which we think would have also been
counterproductive with respect to the
economy but let me get back to this
growth point because just don't forget
that you need economic growth and if we
keep saying we'll just have what we call
static revenue increases that makes it
really hard to get tax reform and here's
where we have differences as well we're
we're patty who I I liked patty a lot we
have good honest confident agreements
with each other they want tax reform as
a means to growing revenue to the
government we want tax reform as a means
to growing the economy to getting people
back to work what that means to us is
lowering tax rates not closing loopholes
in keeping high tax rates it's closing
loophole
lowering tax rate acorrea never knew
that is brought out of it that seems to
be so why don't we have the Ways and
Means Committee and Senate Finance
Committee's put together legislation put
together tax reforms and see what those
look like that's something I think we
should do that's something that I think
we should have that exercise so Max
Baucus Dave can't parallel track starts
you all needs to start go get him and
unlikely how did that happen what's that
the likelihood of that happening we're
doing it in the house we're moving
forward so we're going to boxing camp
did do an op ed I want to say about it
month ago claiming that they and I think
they're both genuine about it he's in
his last tournament ways and means
Bacchus in his last term is that gonna
get moving we want to we're going to do
it or not in the house whether the
Senate follows or not we're gonna move
for now here's my point I'm trying to
make on this I the president says he
wants to take the corporate rate down to
28% good idea problem is that's only 20%
of American businesses 80% of American
businesses aren't corporations they file
their taxes as individuals subchapter S
corporations and LLC's partnerships
they're effective top tax rate goes up
to like 44 percent now with the January
tax increase that makes it pretty hard
for them to compete internationally when
the international tax rate on businesses
is 25 percent so this is why we take
this very seriously 9 out of 10
businesses in Wisconsin they're not
corporations they're what we call pass
throughs so we want to get those tax
rates down equally not just the big
corporate you want to make a revenue
neutral business and you want to make a
revenue news in order to get the tax
rates down when we need them to go to be
competitive and internationally
competitive yeah you need that fiscal
space plugging loopholes to get the
rents down but if you do that somebody
faxes are going up whose taxes are going
but people who lose their tax shelters
and that's it that's people in the high
end who people in the high end you're
not the mortgage thing that's with any
of these other middle classes everything
is on the table everything on the table
and this are you were in the Ways and
Means committees we're not going to take
anything off the table because we think
once we start getting in this game of
picking winners and losers in the tax
code which is what the tax code does
today we won't have a good alpha codes
been that way for a long time well you
know in 86 Rostenkowski pack o'neill
reagan bradley they came together and
they got this done that's the kind of
thing we want to see happen again
we would like to think there's an
opportunity for a bipartisan agreement
on tax reform which gets us growth we
would like to think we could get to a
bipartisan agreement on entitlement
reform and that's the kind of agreement
want to see at the end of the day I am
running out of time I did have a
Facebook question from you from a Peter
north of Massachusetts and it was in a
one-off but I'm curious could you ever
imagining it's about lifting the income
gap the income cap on Social Security
contribution can you ever imagine a
raising that or even creating a doughnut
hole that raised it on more wealthier
folks on contributing more as a way to
fix or make Social Security solvent for
longer I think there's a better way to
do it without economic problems which is
means-test the spending means-test the
benefit formula itself doesn't sound
like you're totally ruling out the idea
there's the raising of some of that when
you rate when you lift the cap you know
you also pay out a benefit you get
fifteen cents on the dollar
at that level of income mm-hmm and so
what where does conversation Everly goes
I've been on a number of commissions I
look at this is well we should cut the
benefit off you know we if if Aaron
Rodgers is gonna pay you know his FICA
tax and all of his salary by the way he
should be the highest-paid player in the
and I you know total common ground here
there should be a resolution that's
passed so but but but then he'll have a
huge benefit most policymakers say well
that's not fair then cut that off then
you turn it into a welfare program and
it's not like a social insurance program
most of us want to make sure that this
has the feel of a social insurance
program and not a welfare redistribution
program second point is what about the
self-employed person what about the
dentist with a few chairs what about the
farmer their income tax rate goes up
over 50% very bad for self-employed
people bad for economic growth so the
tax increases I think are the wrong way
to go because it produces bad economic
output but let's focus on means testing
the benefit formula itself you can get
the kind of same kind of savings without
doing a devastation to the self-employed
can your dr2 jobs not only have double
zeros but I'm also getting yelled at in
a monitor that says I got to go
introduce the next guy so anyway
Congressman Paul Ryan chairman of the
House Budget Committee
thank you so much anybody may come back
and I'm not kidding I am getting yelled
at in the monitor there's no exclamation
points but it's an all caps and we all
know how that feels now our next guest
is somebody who is not only a current
senator Ohio senator Rob Portman
Republican from Ohio but somebody who
was the head of OMB the Office of
Management and Budget during the Bush
administration so somebody who's
well-versed in budget issues and we'll
see we'll see where he stands
he's now chit-chatting and doing doing I
think some green room negotiating with
Paul Ryan there but anyway let me
introduce Rob Portman
you give me an entrance we did you it's
sort of like it's sort of like at a
baseball game do you have specific
entrance music that you demand I had
preferred a country fluoride or
something like this yeah stairway to
heaven sterling I am and that's another
way to talk about the budget it's kind
of played out without knowing what wants
to do what I wanted to there it is I
truly thought that Paul Ryan was the
only heavy metal rock fan yeah I go
where or wind another way thank you for
having me on Gene Sperling is supposed
to be speaking now I apologize to those
who who are you guys are switching
Regine all the gene fans were here but
we've got a vote in the Senate so gene
kind of let me go ahead he did say to me
when he told you threatened him when you
sent him to see well when is this a
threat when I was changing his schedule
he said Rob I'll do it but you may
regret this and so I'm saying but
seriously thank you gene and I have done
this before this dog and pony show
together so I was interested in him
going first because it's a lot more fun
to criticize what someone else says
about they actually come up with ideas
so well then there you go
yeah I want to start the same question
I've started with Senator Murray I've
said and I don't have a good answer
which is nobody seems to want to start
negotiating Paul Ryan made it clear that
they're not ready yet to start the
conference process they want to have
sort of a side negotiation first they
don't think they're in a good place
the demmer Senate Democrats you were
probably on the Senate floor last night
and saw this exchange between Harry Reid
and Ted Cruz which got a little ugly
there the end about trying to start the
negotiating clock why won't the clock
start well I think there to negotiations
one is the formal negotiation and a
budget resolution and given the budget
that was passed in the Senate I think
the difference between the House and
Senate is so great that that's not
likely to be suggested not not a useful
exercise well I think it's because I
think we need reconciliation at the end
of the process but not having the
president's involvement and having a
more middle ground approach that the
administration can bring to the table if
they choose to would make it very
difficult to make any progress on these
two very different approaches to the
budget the real negotiation has to take
place in my view between the president
and and those of us in Congress who want
to get something done and that is
beginning I was there these dinners
president golfing with a couple of
people that we assumed would be part of
this group of 16 or 20 of Republicans
that way to be saxby chambliss got a
hole-in-one yesterday which means that
there will be no tax increases which i
think is great it greatly so they bet on
that what with what it was straight to
the contrary he he actually asked me to
golf with him which was a huge mistake
because I am so bad I'm such a hacker
the President had the three from my
understanding mark Udall sakelik
Chambliss are the two best golfers in
the Senate is that yeah that's also a
corker played well yesterday said but he
was really lucky I wasn't out there and
the course was lucky I mean a lot of
divots so we have these 16 to 20
Republicans this is what this is how
this process is going to go patty Murray
and Paul Ryan or basically they've got
their budgets they've done what they've
had to do there'll be a busy process all
between a group of you and the president
no I mean I think everybody's gonna be
involved I mean I in this town you know
nothing happens behind closed doors
which is okay this needs to be something
that is transparent at the end of the
day this is gonna affect the lives of
millions of Americans and fundamental
ways and so you know it's gonna be a
processor be able to involved Patty will
be involved of course Paul will be
involved but it requires presidential
leadership and you know I've talked
about this before but if you look back
whether it's tax reform 86 or whether
it's Social Security form 83 really the
last two examples where we did something
significant to try to improve the
economy and deal with our at that point
what seemed to be a huge debt and
deficit problem which by the way seems
small relative what we have now it has
always involved presidential leadership
it must first the president's kind of
ultimately be supportive in order to
have it become effective and inactive
but second the resources of the Office
of Management and Budget that I used to
head in the Treasury Department so on
are critical to this so you know the
president's got to step up and show
leadership and did he not with this
budget do you believe he started he
started in a small way and I think
that's important as you know I've talked
a lot about that publicly and privately
and our hearings we've had on the
President's budget talking about the
fact that the putting chained CPI on the
table at all
think is a step in the right direction
saying in the budget for the first time
by the way that the savings that come
from reducing some of the preferences in
the corporate tax code ought to go back
into lowering the rate rather than being
used for deficit reduction generally I
think was a positive step that's in the
budget the first time so I think you you
take those small steps in the right
direction and you build on them and look
the president's taking some heat from
his side of the aisle and change CPI and
some members of the Republican Party
seem to want more interested in the
politics of this I mean you had chair
well the House Republican you know the
campaign committee Greg wall say just
that yeah look was that it's a more
accurate measure of inflation it's the
right thing to do in my view from a
policy point of view in terms of the
politics there are Republicans who
believe that we should wait until wait
for what until we can have another
election
perhaps one wasn't good enough perhaps
getting a majority in 2014 in the Senate
perhaps getting a new president 2016 I
don't think the country can wait I mean
I honestly believe that we're in trouble
as a country both in terms of the fiscal
problem but also in terms of our economy
and if we wait until 2017 which is in
essence what that's saying that attitude
I think we're taking a huge risk and so
I I think we have to engage and I'm not
suggesting that my people share your
view in the Senate and you're in the
conference Republican Compton from
Congress I think the majority honestly
do you yeah I do I mean I think there
are some who you know unlikely to be
there almost no matter what but there
are others who are gonna take a hard
look at this who who might surprise you
I mean I think there are a lot of
members who understand that this is a
pivotal point in our nation's history
it's not just about getting through the
debt limit it's about dealing with what
is otherwise going to be a huge impact
on people we represent because our
standard of living will go down because
we are risking a financial crisis it
would make the one in oh and oh nine
look relatively small you look right now
what's happening you know yeah the stock
market's looking pretty good the wages
are going down I mean so ii it's an
economic issue too
there's a real squeeze out there health
care costs up wages down you know people
who are serious legislators on both
sides of the aisle recognize that this
is a pivotal point and we have to act
and by the way if you think about it in
the past dealing with issues like tax
reform
teittleman's I mentioned 83 and 86 it
tends to come with divided government
George Bush tried this as you recall
with Social Security when there was a
Republican Congress didn't get very far
no in part because of the politics
they're tough no question about it it's
that third rail of the New York subway
system you grab and you're electrocuted
right and if you grab it together you
sort of spread the shock a little bit
and and that that's the opportunity that
I see really in the next several months
here and we got to take advantage of it
I've had some Senate Democrats and I
don't not not the Senate Democrat that
was up here but some Senate Democrats
whisper to be named unnamed say don't
Republicans realize they'll never have
an easier negotiating partner on the
other side of the aisle than President
Obama in fact they say this out of some
of that is out of fear they think
President Obama is going to be more of a
compromiser than they would be in the
Senate Democrats do how many Republicans
sort of either believe that that is true
well Chuck you and I may disagree on
this but the President had an
opportunity with his own fiscal
commission to step up he chose not to he
rejected to her
recommend you think if he endorsed
bowles-simpson unequivocally at that
time owned it and it the only place to
find it right now is on whitehouse.gov I
always like pointing that out folks but
if he had endorsed that owned it do you
really believe there would have been
bipartisan support for life would have
been very different you had as you know
senators including all the Republicans
who showed up to work on that Commission
Tom Coburn being one a very conservative
senator supporting it I mean it would
have been it would have been very
different bunch of Republicans jumped
off didn't end up that Commission could
have had teeth on it that Commission the
President had as a point because a bunch
of senators backed out including some
Democrats but look my point is this if
you look this president's record in
terms of his inability to show
leadership on this issues there's no
wonder there's some skepticism when Paul
Ryan came out with his budget instead of
saying there's some tough stuff we can
do here this is the budget from last
year there was a frontal attack you know
with Paul sit in the front row and so I
understand the skepticism it's a healthy
skepticism it's based on some of the
previous actions of the administration
or inaction
but I think those Democrats are making a
point that we ought up we ought to we
ought to listen to and look meaning you
do buy into the idea that you probably
know you might get a better deal from
President Obama than you would from
Harry Reid I mean it's trust but verify
but not to even engage I think is a huge
mistake I mean you know let's see
whether he's serious or not if he's
sincere I do believe we can do something
significant it may not be called the
grand bargain but folks unless we get
started both on the economic growth side
of this which is in my view tax reform
and then also on dealing with this
long-term problem which is not going to
be solved unless we get at the mandatory
spending which is now about 65 percent
of the budget growing at a faster rate
than the rest of the budget CBO just
told us that Medicare Medicaid and
Social Security incredibly vital
programs and we've got to save them but
that they will grow it ninety five
percent over the next ten years they'll
grow by almost double
they've also told us by the way that if
we don't do something on the spending
side we'll go from about 22% of GDP
today to about 39 percent in three
decades historic average is you know is
20% over the last 50 years
you can't catch that with enough taxes
it's simply not possible so when folks
talk about balance you ought to ask them
why they're talking about revenues which
are now projected to be at 19% spending
at 39% this isn't a few decades this is
not you know like next century are they
talking about 29% is that the balance if
so higher taxes by far apart you've ever
had you want in doubling of all of your
taxes we couldn't get there in my view
with 100% taxes on the wealthy so we
have to come up with a new tax form
based on the historical data on what it
was like we had a 70 percent tax rate
and so on so when people say like me we
could cure for spending this is as Bill
Clinton said famously at the Democratic
convention in another context it's math
I mean this is not ideology but do you
want rhythm in it
you walk in but speaking of ideology I
feel like I heard some from from Senator
Murray when it came to the issue of
Medicare age and
like I heard some of it from Paul Ryan
when it came to the issue of taxes and
revenue do you walk into this saying I'm
not gonna be a part of any deal that
includes any more tax increases no I
walk into it saying we've got to solve
the issue which is spending and if
there's a sincere effort on spending and
if we come up with some changes that are
really structural changes to begin to
bend the curve and if we do tax reform
not just in an end it's up raising
revenue and then ends up raising a
little revenue you can sign onto
something like that look I mean we'll
see I I do think that see we're making
progress right we well why and rightly I
think that one of the factors we had a
look at is behavioral changes and
therefore what people call macroeconomic
or dynamic scoring and as you know in
the budget debate in the Senate I
offered an amendment that was actually
passed by the United States Senate did
suggest we should have the benefit of
looking at the dynamics core why did I
want that so badly because both how you
design tax reform and how you look at
this issue in terms of revenue ought to
include what the Congressional Budget
Office and the Joint Committee on
taxation not some of these outside
groups of what our internal analysis
says in terms of what the macroeconomic
impact is going to be and it will show
with regard to the business tax reform
which is you know I'm mm-hmm very
focused on because if we don't do this
we're gonna continue to lose jobs and
businesses overseas and on the
individual side there will be revenue
increased through growth now the
president's gonna insist on some static
scored revenue he says in order to do
anything on entitlements those of us who
are interested in getting to yes we're
gonna have to look at that and look at
it in the context of what other aspects
of tax reform are going to help the
economy so this will be the discussion
and by the way it is a discussion that
has been taking place really for five or
six years you look at these other
Commission now feels like there's all
these things on the Shelf you can just
pick and choose it's even a la carte
right I like this room from Alice Rivlin
like this one from Alan Simpson is it is
it that easy you think it's not quite
that easy because there's a little thing
in the Congress called scoring so yeah
people say just pick up this proposal
well when you go through the process for
instance on tax reform you've got those
two Joint Committee on taxation and
you've got
by their score in order to legislate so
legislating is a little more difficult
than coming up with a recommendation of
commission but having said that there
are a lot of good ideas out there we're
not lacking ideas we're lacking
political will and I do believe that if
we don't solve this problem again we put
the country in great jeopardy all right
let me get a Facebook question in here
direct it to you from Cynthia Coombs
from Louisville Kentucky what policies
can be put in place today that can help
our country train and prepare a
workforce for the jobs of tomorrow so a
little one off in the conversation this
goes into this larger debate about its
use how government spends some money
yeah there is some joint agreement that
government should spend some money on
things like this yeah look one of the
huge issues we face in our economy today
is the skills gap we have 400,000 people
in Ohio looking for a job today we have
a hundred thousand jobs open why is that
it's primarily because those people who
are looking to not have the skills to
fill the 100,000 jobs that open in Ohio
so people say unemployment's going down
not really if you look at the labor
participation rate if you just assume
that the same labor participation mean
people in the workforce are looking for
work as when the recession began we're
at eleven point three percent on them
well don't forget that some of this is
there a lot of this is demographics some
of this demographic and we have an older
pilot aging color but that doesn't
account for the lowest labor
participation rate since 1979 says Jimmy
Carter was president so my point is
there's a huge skills gap here one thing
the federal government can do that I'd
love to have to be part of this final
agreement if they take the worker
retraining programs that are done at the
federal level because we have between
fifteen and eighteen billion dollars a
year Chuck that we're spending and have
it worked much better to close that gap
right now there are 46 programs spread
over nine different departments and
agencies and the GAO has studied it and
said there's all kinds of duplication
waste inefficiency I happen to have
legislation on this with Mike Bennett
Democrat from Colorado is the former
superintendent so you feel like there is
a way to consolidate though there is
streamlined consolidate put performance
tests in place ensure that the skills
people are getting are actually needed
in the region there's all sorts of
opportunities here for the federal
government to partner better with the
states this is one of four or five
things that this country needs to do
right now to avoid us from continuing to
fall behind
where
I'm just curious where should this be
housed you know everything has got to be
have somewhere in the government well
though to the Labor Department is
education it's a bit labor with with
with we're the Workforce Investment Act
and NTIA
the Trade Adjustment Assistance and and
and that's good that's that's fine but
it should be something that is not
spread over all these other departments
and agencies and and there are
opportunities here for us to get people
to work right away if we provide the
training to two out questions debt
ceiling looks like now it looks like
September October yeah is it going to be
a crisis when it comes up and if so do
you actually need it is it going to be
needed as the trigger to force the talks
yes so it is gonna be a crisis and it's
needed yes
so you're of the mindset let that could
be the forcing mechanism to the big bull
look I've heard the president say you
know we should take this you know out of
the political equation and just extend
the debt limit and then deal separately
with this I will tell you that over the
last three decades it's the only thing
that has worked
think about gramm-rudman that was the
rescission some of you there's no one
room old enough to remember Graham
government I can see but but it came out
of well we want to pretend there's
nobody in this room old enough to
remember grand Rudman that's a debt
limit discussion yeah
think about the 1990 budget deal that
some criticized the George HW Bush put
in place what did that come out of it he
did a debt limit crisis as did the 97
agreement the balanced budget agreement
1997 so I would argue that every single
one of the half-dozen proposals that
have actually worked to reduce spending
in Congress in the last three decades
has come out of this same process why
because the American people do not like
to extend the debt limit why because
they get it it's like a credit card
you've overextended on your credit card
now you're going back to Congress and
saying because you have to understand
tend that well what the American people
say is deal with the underlying problem
like I'd have to do in my home or my
business when my teenager maxes out on
his or her card and so it's a it's a
good leverage point because the American
people get it because they don't want us
to extend it without dealing with the
underlying problem I think this will be
a positive way for us to focus people's
attention come whatever it is September
October and it's this year this year is
deal or bust I think it does I think
it's very difficult to imagine in 2014
which is
it's possible we've done things in
election year before but it's gonna be
difficult and they have this summit next
year we're gonna be talking about the
deal I hope we're talking about
implementation of something that we have
agreed to early as fall and I hope we're
talking about the fact that we now have
some bending of this curve that is
otherwise going to bankrupt the country
there's no question about it
and and I hope we're talking about an
economy that started to improve because
people see they have more certainty with
regard to a pro-growth tax reform
because we're dealing with some of these
issues like worker retraining we talked
about and that America gets back on
track senator rob portman
thank John from Ohio can see it believe
it there gene is waiting in the wings
don't
he's a threatening individual so the
joke never gets old in for Jean right
every time he gets introduced the
audience is going to live to regret the
joke anyway with that I bring out Gene
Sperling he's chairman of the
president's National Economic Council
and he comes out now a man of many
budget Wars a veteran of many budget
Wars mr. Spurling you are the last word
here on this my privilege you are on the
White House side of things meaning you
have you know you are aware probably
aware of where the levels of
conversation are and I'm going to start
with basically the same question I've
started ever being everybody else what's
the status of talks have they truly
begun between the President and Senate
Republicans that seems to be where
everything this is headed is it fair to
say it's formally begun or not I would
say that what you've seen the president
do is do everything he can to create the
conditions for a bipartisan agreement
and you see that by the fact that he was
willing to keep his offer to Speaker
Boehner on the table even put it in his
budget even after speaker had pulled it
back you've seen it in the outreach that
he has done to Senate Republicans and
really to anyone
he thinks would be part of throwing ball
machines now is that what this has come
down to he's gonna throw that if people
ask are we doing enough I think the fact
that we are arranging for Republican
senators to get holes in one when they
play Goff with the president amazing the
power I'd like it a little I don't know
like a little reform I expect us to do
and we it's a one on one 111 hole I mean
it was it was an extraordinary effort
but it shows that we are taking very
seriously doing everything we can to
create those conditions and I think that
these dinners and the conversations have
been important because they build trust
the Republican senators have seen the
president's very serious they've seen
that he is willing to compromise that
he's willing to destroy now things that
he doesn't necessarily even want to have
particularly in his budget but he's
showing that willingness to compromise I
do think that and you had this
conversation earlier that you'd heard
quite a lot before about the importance
of returning to regular order as you
remember I think when I'm often being
interviewed on cable TV I used to get if
only the Senate we have a budget 1,000
for whatever it is right heard it so
many times so here you've had that take
place they even condition the debt limit
extension on it and so we have a chance
to actually have a conference committee
like we teach our kids and their US
government classes it's supposed to work
and yet you don't even see a willingness
to appoint conferees but I think what
we're doing is obviously we're calling
for regular order but the president is
engaged in the conversations that I
think soften the ground create the
conditions for an agreement and that's
not and I think you know the importance
of what you saw in his budget is is that
it's not just about having quiet
conversations he has shown that he is
willing to go out of his comfort zone to
put forward a real compromise to take
heat even from his own side
understanding that in divided government
if we're going to get a balanced
agreement it is going to require both
sides to get less than a hundred percent
both sides to be willing to tell their
supporters that we have to come
premised to do something positive to
move the country forward I mean one
thing I think it's important to
recognize is is how nonsensical the
status quo is right now
I mean everyone has said it but it's
true you have a sequester that was
designed by both sides to be so stupid
that it wouldn't take place Speaker
Boehner had said it would be devastating
and then people say well I think the
Republicans leadership may be satisfied
with the status quo but on what
substantive grounds they have always
argued for a stronger defense budget
this has a harsh defense cut that lasts
for 10 years they argue for stronger
border security
this cuts border security some of them
support more biomedical research this is
one and a half to two billion dollars a
year in cuts to NIH and this is the most
important point I want to make which is
what you hear when you come to a Pete
Peterson Forum is a focus on how we as a
country are going to deal with the
challenge of the baby boom retirement so
the question to ask is what does the
sequester do for the second decade of
savings and the answer is it is a big
zero I think it's important for people
to understand that this cuts the nonde
the domestic part of our budget which is
already about to be the lowest it's been
as a percentage of our economy since the
1950s it would cut this severely even
though that's where a lot of our
investments in children and innovation
and research are and then it has a small
cut in entitlement savings which and
this is important ends exactly on the
tenth year it goes away so when you look
at the sequester somebody says they're
serious about long-term entitlement
savings but they think the status quo is
acceptable therefore an approach that
would have zero savings in the second
ten years compared to the president's
approach which would have one to two
trillion dollars of entitlement savings
in the second decade well we as you know
a big deal happens in Washington when
there is a political reward for both
sides at the end is it fair to say when
you see how Republicans they're not
paying a political
my son sequester as far in their own
districts they don't believe that they
are doesn't that tell you that this sort
of the the politics of spending has
changed in such a way that the
Republicans are just going to be in
another place well you know again I
don't understand what substantive goal
it serves for them again this is cutting
into areas that they have long argued
where priorities for them it's done in
an arbitrary way you know you've heard
both Paul Ryan and Rob Portman talk
about growth there is not a single
independent economic forecaster out
there or not one I've seen that does not
think the sequester is costing us
hundreds of thousands of jobs costing us
economic growth we're at a point where
we should be where our economy recovery
is showing some strength in the housing
side we could be taking off instead
we're putting the brick on the economy
so why should people be satisfied with
an approach that was designed to be so
stupid nobody could live with it that's
hurting jobs
that's hurting economic growth you know
one can take that position but I don't
understand that and I do believe that
there are military communities in many
people's districts and other places
people getting meals-on-wheels Head
Start programs that are hurting and I
think I'm not sure that people aren't
hearing that but it is true as you know
Mitch McConnell one says it takes two to
tango and the presidents can create a
conditions and he can do outreach for a
serious bipartisan balanced agreement
that can help alleviate this remove the
sequester and have a more balanced
approach of long-term entitlement
savings and revenue from tax reform but
you know again it takes two to tango the
president has shown real political
courage and leadership and what he's
been willing to put out but if we don't
see some of that same leadership and
courage from their side it's going to be
very hard for us to do anything about
that and we understand that's the
reality we face what did the president
mean when he said the other day that
there needs to be a permission
structure for the Republicans to get on
board it was an interesting phrase that
he used that that we was asked about the
dinners and all this but it seemed that
we're sort of kind of still in this
stalemate and he said he was trying to
create this idea where there has to be a
permission structure for Republicans to
get on board well I think in divided
government you when you have a budget
agreement you're right I've been part of
this I was one of the negotiators in
1997
you know deficit reduction is never easy
it's never fun it requires hard choices
and when you have divided government
whether it's 1997 or now it requires
compromise and I think what you need
though is for both sides to be able to
feel that they achieved enough of their
objectives that the compromise in the
areas they don't like is acceptable
because the plan as a whole is balanced
well we care about and I think many
progressive Democrats care about is that
you want a plan that's going to be good
for jobs and growth now because we need
this recovery to strengthen for for to
help alleviate long-term unemployment
help middle-class families you need a
budget agreement that allows us to still
invest in the future and you need
something that while it will have
long-term entitlement savings isn't
putting all the burden on seniors and
middle-class families that it's balanced
that includes some revenue savings from
the most high end individuals and I
think if it has that kind of balance it
is easier for a Democrat to go along
with perhaps some measures that they
would normally oppose likewise I think
what you've heard when you listen to
Senator Portman and others is that while
they may prefer to not have any
additional revenues through tax reform
if the agreement is serious enough about
long-term entitlement savings such as in
the second decade as we spoke about that
I think that for them becomes acceptable
even if they would prefer not to have
revenues they hopefully many of them on
both sides recognize that everyone's got
to give a little everyone's got a
compromise or positional little so that
we can have an honorable agreement
that's good for growth good for the
middle class good for the confidence
that comes from showing we're dealing
with our long-term entitlement challenge
is there a part of the Ryan budget that
you could and in specifically the
Medicare plan that the president could
adopt like except a dot you know in a
larger deal well you know if you look at
what I'm trying to have a negotiation
now open the air yeah well just what you
guys hate you know we've always thought
this negotiation would happen with you
and so I've come ready I preview it
appreciate it but let me I'll be very
specific December third Paul Ryan
Speaker Boehner Majority Leader Cantor
right the president a letter saying that
if we're going to accept eight hundred
billion in revenues are we be willing to
a hundred billion in revenues if you
took this deal that Erskine Bowles had
suggested to the supercommittee
and that deal basically called for three
things they called for raising the
Medicare retirement age it called for
CPI and it called for means testing
Medicare I do think that the president
and then the Minority Leader McConnell
called for those same three things twice
in November and then on his first
appearance on Meet the Press in January
if you look at what the president has
done he has put forward in his budget
two of their explicit requests means
testing the premiums on Medicare for
couples over 170,000 and also accepting
their requests that we have the CPI
change in the budget and you see that
obviously that's been very tough and
some of our own supporters have
expressed opposition to that so I do
think that the president has shown a
willingness to go at least halfway but
one thing people don't recognize enough
is that when the president puts out in
his budget 400 billion in specific
savings and Medicare and then you say
how does that compare to Paul Ryan's
budget I don't know how to answer that
because they don't have any details of
how they get any savings in the
ten years none so we hear a lot about
are you for structural reform well the
president says here's 400 billion this
includes asking high-income premiums on
well-off seniors it does call for new
beneficiaries to have some better
incentives in in their beneficiary
structure so we've got details on the
table there's now time for the
Republicans who are serious to come back
and start saying what it is they want
and what are the connealy they owe you a
deal they owe you a new piece of paper
that you guys have if we're doing a
ping-pong game here a little bit you
guys have put out your public ping-pong
you you've done your shot oh you
something in return I think that I think
that even some of them recognized that
to some degree the ball is in their
court even if it's a private
communication and look you know of
course I've heard the speaker and others
say well the president got his revenues
but let's be honest the speaker was at a
trillion dollars in revenues in December
a trillion so it is true that 620
billion dollars was raised by restoring
the rates to the Clinton rates but even
by their last offer they have nearly
four hundred billion in revenues on the
table it's not as much as the five
hundred eighty billion the president has
asked for but the fact is we shouldn't
there shouldn't be this absolutist
position from them that you can't have
any revenue because they've already
explained they want to do a deal what's
that you think they want to do look I've
kind of given up on trying to read minds
and motives and incentives I think that
I think that you'll regret if you read
it read it if you eye I do think let's
just stipulate that I'm a very
intimidating and threatening person and
then we can go on look I think that I
have conversations with Republicans who
I think are sincere about being willing
to compromise I think they want to see a
significant commitment to the type of
entitlement savings as part of the deal
I think that they understand
that to get an agreement divided
government that means the tax reform
would have to raise some revenue to
contribute do you buy this idea that you
can lower rates and raise revenue well I
I think it's it's it's difficult but I
think you know you said what the
president has done is he has put out
explicitly how he would raise five
hundred eighty billion dollars through
two reforms the Buffett Rule and having
a 28 percent deduction limit so he has
shown how you could do it in a way that
is reformed and he feels is fair to the
middle class but he's always been clear
that he doesn't claim to have all the
good ideas in the world and if some and
if the Congress was come back in a
bipartisan way with a tax reform that
raised that amount of revenue and met
his basic fairness goals that he's open
to other ideas now can you raise that
much revenue for deficit reduction and
still raise enough to lower rates it's
very difficult but the president's never
put that off the table I do think when
you look at what the House Republicans
are talking about going down to 25% and
that has two problems one you know
everything that chairman Ryan said today
unfortunately all left the line that
there couldn't be a single penny of
revenues which is not going to help us
lead to a bipartisan agreement but also
I think as we saw from the report from
the Brookings Urban Institute over the
over the summer if you have to lower
rates that much on top one percent you
can't cut their expenditures enough to
pay for it so you'd have to actually go
through ease taxes on middle-class
families and I think if they were to put
forward a plan like that in detail have
it scored now people understand it I
don't think it would do very well the
debt ceiling you heard Rob Portman say
there's no choice debt ceiling I know
where the president stands on this he
said it's not negotiate he's not gonna
use it he's not gonna be forced to
negotiating you having the debt ceiling
VA
negotiating mechanism how is it not
inevitable look the president's been
very clear he's not negotiating on the
debt limit he believes that the era of
anyone threatening though arguably he's
done it twice I mean BCA in 11 and even
the end of the year the idea of
negotiating the debt I mean there has
been negotiation through it in some form
or not as it not there there was in 2011
and what we saw was how harmful that was
the idea that the United States who and
all that we've done over 200 plus years
since Alexander Hamilton to build up our
credit rating our Full Faith and Credit
I think that when the president saw what
happened in 2011 saw the hit to
confidence the hit to the economy to hit
to our standing I think he made the
right decision which is that he's simply
not going to negotiate on the debt limit
that no one should ever threaten the
default of the United States as a way of
getting their budget goals you you're
not better than having it the record of
forced budget talks no because the
because no one Democrat a Republican for
any reason should ever use the default
of the United States as a budget tactic
or a negotiating tool and I also want to
make clear that this you know this very
bad piece of legislation that may be
coming through the house called
prioritization is you know
prioritization is default by another
name it is not a proposal to prevent
default it is a proposal that says who
do you pay first when you are in default
yeah I mean it's the equivalent of
telling its equivalent of telling a
relative it's okay if you pay your
mortgage it's okay if you default on
your student loan your car loan and your
credit card the United States when we
talk about our Full Faith and Credit
we mean that unites the United States of
America meets its obligations and the
idea that it would be okay for us to
meet our obligations to bondholders but
then default to veteran
to Medicare recipients to small business
contractors is completely unacceptable
and no one should think that is anything
other than default by another name is
that what's your level of confidence
that a big deal actually gets done that
he signs a big deal piece of legislation
on the budget that's sort of that sort
of you know it's a putz a new battle for
five or ten I know and I'm so good at
this that I would get it exactly right
but then there'd be so little for people
of your profession today I mean are you
is it a better than 50/50 chance or now
already are you less optimistic than
that what's realistic I think all we can
do every day I mean this is wake up and
do everything we can to create the
conditions for that type of and this is
the last chance this five-month period
is realistically the last chance well I
think his forest presidency look I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna you know make you
know two month or three and a half year
projections I think historically as we
saw 97 the first year of a president's
second term is a good time for people to
come together and make hard choices that
are that are good for the country and
again you've seen this hasn't been
abstract you've seen the president out
there willing to accept things they need
for a budget agreement that he doesn't
necessarily agree with you've seen him
show the political courage of doing
things that many of his own supporters
disagreed with I think that what's been
important about the outreach is that
people understand that he's having
private conversations senators can call
the White House Republican senators and
the door would be opened to Republican
House members to have private
conversation so people know that whether
we've reached that deal space or not
they understand that the president's
serious
he's about getting something done he's
willing to compromise and I think what
he's doing is in a period of dysfunction
where we have this harmful sequester
he's showing the country that there's
another way forward Gene Sperling
president of the the chairman of the NEC
no promotion rail promotion yes thank
you the double zero
thanks to everybody patty Murray Paul
Ryan Rob Portman and James filling at
the last word thank you guys very much
and thank you to the Peterson foundation
for letting me do this I enjoyed it all
right what's that oh I got one more this
was this was this was new to me display
now we have one more Democrat on board
another one a veteran of the budget wars
my apologies Maryland congressman Chris
Van Hollen Democrat the ranking member
on the Budget Committee with Paul Ryan
hey Chuck
I was how you do it Leslie's away I you
know rule I no no this morning you got a
invitation to join the Budget Committee
if I apparently too much a few so there
was a proposal a couple of right before
the last recess that said the conference
committee between the two budgets was
going to be Paul Ryan a Republican of
his choice you patty Murray Ron Wyden
and and Jeff Sessions on the Republican
side and that the six of you we're gonna
start getting together hey where is
where does that stand is that even a
plausible beginning scenario for how the
House and Senate begin this
reconciliation process well we'd like to
do that Chuck we meaning patty Murray
who's asked to go to conference
Democrats in the House and the Budget
Committee we want to go to conference
that is the next step you know
Republicans justifiably complained that
the Senate didn't have a budget for
three years now they have a budget you
have a house you say justifiably
complained that with my fail in other
words I think it was a fair point I mean
to say you know the you know the Senate
should come up with a budget that was a
fair point
they said it everywhere in the country
that was their big talking point now the
question we've got is whether they
prefer that as a talking point or
whether they actually really want to get
a budget because they made a big deal
about no budget no pay but the reality
is we still don't have a budget we're
now past the April 15th deadline in
statue
for Congress to complete conference
committee action again they made a big
point about the president's budget do
you know is violation of the
Congressional this is me dead life you
guys lose your pay well you know we're
gonna have to press our Republican
colleagues on this but we should go to
conference I mean I think people expect
us to that take the next step in the
process and we've been waiting they keep
saying well they want to have these
conversations but I can tell you that
that's really not happening right now
Ryan he said that it caught that it that
the I guess he was implying that the
environments not ready for the
conference that that it would just that
he he believes that for instance the
president's chain CPI initiative there
would be a massive bipartisan resolution
voting it down because of the way the
conference process works and that once
you start that clock it could make the
process harder what are you saying
response my response is the clock is
ticking right now there's no evidence
that we are getting any closer to
agreement and so going to conference and
beginning the clock ticking is a little
bit of an action-forcing mechanism
people will begin to say okay well why
should we're going to negotiate with you
and patty murray if the president's deal
is already a better deal well the
reality is that what happens in
conference will include any ideas that
have been raised by the White House or
others it's not as if the the White
House is somehow excluded entirely from
the conference process I mean obviously
they're important player here Gene
Sperling just talked about the ideas the
president put on the table but you know
what's ironic you know they talked about
how the president has changed CPI it was
their idea and they don't have it in the
Republican budget so you're going to
conference neither side that didn't have
chained CPI even though this was their
request I mean look this is why I think
it's important just to have a structure
to force the conversation and we
shouldn't be using the debt ceiling for
example and playing around and
negotiating with our Full Faith and
Credit as Gene Sperling said we should
be using the budget process so if you
have regular order what
that due to the president working with
Senate Republicans does it help your
cause hurt your cause or is it just a
separate track no I think it's a
parallel track that then can feed into
that conversation as you mentioned you
got Jeff Sessions you've got other
Republicans who are on the Budget
Committee in the Senate obviously
working with Paul Ryan in the house so
it's it's a forum for that conversation
to take place and as I said it's a
little bit of an action-forcing
mechanism because number one it happens
in public that doesn't mean people can't
continue to have conversations and
negotiations but I think it would be a
useful way that finally get people's
minds focused but these budgets are so
far apart how does it even begin let's
say we went to conference and you sit
there and and I mean you know it's it is
to use the cliche one budgets for Mars
and one budgets for Venus I mean it
doesn't seem as if we're maybe we're in
the same universe but not the not the
same well there they are far apart
there's no doubt about it
I mean they're as far apart as they've
been before I think that if it had at
the conference anyway says what would I
think actually it wouldn't that benefit
the country and maybe force the parties
to come closer together by having to put
these arguments out in the light of day
after all our Republican colleagues said
for a long time they didn't want to have
these backdoor conversations I heard Rob
Portman talk about presidential
leadership let's remember that in
December after the speaker decided he
couldn't bring back a package that would
get a majority of his own party in the
house he said he didn't want to meet
with the president one-on-one anymore so
I think that having that conversation in
public reinforced by whatever
conversations people want to have could
be useful now look the one of the main
impediments to moving forward obviously
has been the Republican position on
revenue
and they have taken the position that
you cannot close one tax loophole
eliminate one tax break for the purpose
of reducing the deficit that every
dollar you raise in terms of eliminating
tax rate has to go dollar for dollar
into reducing the rates or some other a
break it would be as if Democrats said
okay we agreed that this is not a high
priority spending program so let's cut
that spending program but you know what
you got a backfill that spending dollar
dollar for dollar why should tax
expenditures which are a form of
spending through the tax code get a
totally different treatment in these
negotiations and yet that's that's
obviously been an impediment look as
Jean pointed out back in December the
speaker said number one he would do a
trillion dollars in revenue
he also said he had a plan to raise 800
billion dollars by eliminating tax
breaks he said he had a plan I would
like to see that plan because that plan
raised revenue not by raising the rates
but by eliminating certain tax
expenditures so you didn't get the
positive speaker you know you think
that's possible well mr. speaker if you
had a plan in December do you believe it
why don't you put it for a raise eight
hundred billion dollars in lower rates
another tax code pre-pre the six hundred
billion you think that's that's a is it
oh is it possible to both lower rates
and raise that amount oh I think that
actually is is possible the issue of
course is how much you're gonna lower
rates by and and after all there's a
there's a lot of Running Room between
800 billion which they said they could
raise and four trillion dollars which
they claim they can eliminate in terms
of tax expenditures to reduce the tax
rate to 25 percent remember they say
they can reduce tax expenditures by
approximately four trillion dollars to
buy down the rate from thirty nine to
twenty five percent so certainly you can
generate 800 billion dollars through tax
reform how much you can lower the rate
by
still generate you know it is another
question but we'd like to see it in
other words put put your own plan that
you had in secret on the table that
would be Kent marking you support the
president's chain CPI initiative and the
means-testing on Medicare to things that
are not in this well the the issue with
with chained CPI is it's presented as a
more accurate measure of inflation so
the extent that's true as a policy
matter that makes sense the problem is
as it relates to seniors there's a lot
of evidence that suggests it's not true
because seniors purchase they use a
greater share of their income on health
care healthcare generally has been
rising faster in terms of price that
other goods in the economy and therefore
they end up paying a higher share of
income higher flexion so that's kind of
a factual question that's a concern as
it relates to seniors other parts of the
chained CPI which also help produce the
deficit
it seems to me makes sense in terms of
Medicare look on Medicare Part B has
already got a lot of means testing the
president has proposed some additional
modest means testing that's certainly
something that can be looked at there
are other proposals the president's made
but our fundamental difference in
approach between the you know on
Medicare has been you know Paul Ryan has
his voucher idea which we believe
doesn't help contain rising health care
costs we believe that just transfers
rising healthcare costs out of the backs
of seniors whose median income is
$22,000 versus the approach we took in
the Affordable Care Act which begins to
move us away from a strictly
fee-for-service system into one that
rewards providers based on quality of
care and can help reduce health care
costs in fact there's some very good
news recently that maybe healthcare
costs per capita are actually rising
more slowly now than at any time in the
last 50 years part of that's do the slow
economy part of that may be due to some
changes in the way people practice
what why should Republicans negotiate
though with you and patty Murray
I mean if well you know there's this
whispering I hear among Democrats who
while both exasperated with Republicans
also are nervous and say you know it's
amazing they don't see that they'll get
a better deal from the president than
they'll ever get from Senate or House
Democrats is that a fair Wow look III
think that all the ideas should be in
the mix you know what what comes out at
the end of the day is got to be part of
the negotiating process but I think you
know the president recognizes let me
first say there's a lot more in common
between the Senate Democratic budget the
House Democrat behind the President's
budget then is different you know
including a major upfront investment in
infrastructure replacement of the
sequester and a balanced approach to
long-term deficit reduction so with the
exception of the items that you just
mentioned not to change CPI there's not
a which of course as I said is not in
the Republicans own budget is not a
significant they're not significant
difference so I think that we could we
could you know we could come to some
agreement now in terms basically you can
envision reluctantly supporting chained
CPI some of this stuff on Medicare if
it's part of a larger D I didn't I said
I didn't say that but I said that we
would look at all the elements in the
President's budget and look at all the
elements certainly in our budget and and
obviously the Republican budget is on
the table for discussion
but yeah we need to take the next step
in the process go to conference why
doesn't the Democratic budget balance
and should it do you believe in a
balanced should should about should the
federal budget be a balanced but well I
think our priority our apse of the
priority has to be economic growth right
in the short term and then longer-term
and that needs to remain our focus and
if that balance can then be a byproduct
of that and if you look at the House
Democratic budget it significantly
reduces
our deficits as percent of GDP in the
ten years and actually our budget
because of what we believe are lower per
capita health care cost growth in the
future actually did balance in the year
2040 which by the way I think everyone
needs to recognize this the Republican
budget last year when did balance in
2040 so this new notion that somehow 10
years from now is a magic number is
totally inconsistent with the budget
they had on the table last year the
other point I would make on this Chuck
is that I mean there is this sort of
super gimmick in the Republican budget
that allows it to get the balance in ten
years which is they they repeal all the
benefits of Obamacare but keep in their
budget because all the other components
of Obamacare that they railed against
taxes so a trillion dollars in revenue
in their budget comes from the
Affordable Care Act and if they don't
get it from there they haven't said
where else they're gonna get it and 715
billion dollars is the Medicare savings
that they railed against in the last
election you take out the 715 and
Medicaid savings and the trillion
dollars in revenue and their budget is
more than a half trillion dollars out of
balance ten years from now so let's just
we need to keep these things in
perspective our focus needs to be
getting the economy going right now
replace the sequester adopt the presence
infrastructure a proposal and then act
now to reduce our long-term deficit in a
steady sustainable way through a
balanced mix of targeted cuts reforms
and revenue from from tax reform you
know you said last week that there's
significant progress has already been
made in long-term deficit reduction do
you believe we are in a crisis a moment
of crisis or not I don't think we're an
immediate deficit crisis today no in
fact I think the main crisis right now
is a jobs deficit we continue to have
high unemployment rates and the
Congressional Budget Office's said if
you look at next year's deficit
three-quarters of next year's deficit is
a result of the fact that we have high
unemployment in other words the economy
is not
potential lots of slack in the economy
so we need to do things to help get the
economy going certainly do no harm so
replace the sequester but yes should we
act now to reduce the long-term deficits
yes if you look at the out years
especially because of demographic shifts
over time it will be kind of become
unsustainable if we don't take action
but we we do in our budget the
president's budget gets the deficit down
to about 1.7 percent of GDP ten years
from now stabilizes the debt and can we
do better yes but let me just say this
in closing because of sort of artificial
budget rules we focus on ten years I
mean there's no magic in ten years I
mean someone could have picked five
years from budgeting someone could have
put fifteen the real issue is to take
four terms of long term take actions now
that phase in over a period of times
we'd be doing everybody by the way
credible way and that that would help us
focus on the real issue you talk about
we do these ten-year projections but we
do a budget every year is that can the
system handle that should it be every
two years at a minimum we you know
you're right well first of all this you
know we haven't got the budget in that
sense we haven't had a budget maybe
every five years of the issue but so it
I could support something like biennial
but I don't I don't feel strongly one
way or another on that appropriations
process that would give them a little
bit more predictability they can do
things on proprietary aleem or says yeah
that's so so you know but you know the
more I look at the budget process stuff
while some of it can help on the margin
it's no substitute for an agreement on
these big substance of issues is it fair
to say if the deal doesn't happen this
year between the president and
Republicans
they'll doesn't happen till 27 we're
sort of where we're in this we're on
this hamster wheel for another four
years I think it's much harder I think
it's much harder because you know right
now you would hope that there's enough
pressure on both sides to try and get an
agreement I'm not sure that there is but
I hope there's enough interest in in
coming together right now and as you
know I mean the presence working it hard
in you know we'd like to go to
conference we should do that right away
president continues to have this
dialogue with the members of the Senate
chris van hollen ranking member House
Democratic Committee would have me and
now I can thank everybody my apologies
on that patty Murray Paul Ryan Gene
Sperling Rob Portman and Chris Van
Hollen these folks they may disagree on
these issues but they are all five I
hope he came across pretty knowledgeable
about this process so and hopefully this
time next year we're talking about the
deal and the incredible deal that
happened because I think one thing we
learned is everybody seems to agree it's
it's this year a bust so thanks for your
for let me do this thank you to be up to
different projects the Peter G Peterson
annual fiscal summit also her